[Music]
sneakers the rubber sold innovation of
the late 1800s became pop culture
Staples by the 1970s and 80s with models
like the Adidas Superstar pumac Clyde
and Nike Air Force 1 but it wasn't until
the release of the Air Jordan in 1985
that sneaker fandom became an
international
Obsession here at peep the cake Sneaker
Convention in New Brunswick New Jersey
resell feed sneaker heads voracious
appetite for Nikes especially as Air
Jordan line this pair all white Jordan
one highs I'm trying to actually sell
her resellers act like speculative
investors stocking up on inventory as a
bet that prices will rise sometimes
yielding enormous profits that's 220
appreciate you bro you got Instagram
yeah but there is one person here who is
not selling Jordans at least not as Nike
conceived of the shoe he goes by the
name naughty and sells a reimagined
version of an Air Jordan 1 under his own
independent clothing label Global
heartbreak we on our third suit he's
part of a controversial segment of the
sneakers Market small label designers
who make products derivative of Air
Jordans and other Nike models this all
just trying to push artwork trying to
push the next man I got a platform why
not use it nauy runs his label out of
his apartment in North Brunswick New
Jersey this my closet man right now this
is probably the only ogs I have I got
them restored like twice because they
start the yellow they start to crack
black Air Force
energy these is only 50 made I probably
spent the most money on these and this
might have been a bad purchase Co
happened and school kicked us out and we
had 60% of our dorming back and I was
like oh yeah let me just make a dumb
decision and these were like
1,800 nauy began Global heartbreak with
only $50 to his name steadily building a
following through Instagram over the
past 6 years this is supposed to be the
needle and this is the broken heart and
the situation I was going through which
is the Heartbreak and then the needle
would be clothing but then it takes two
people to mend the broken heart and sew
it back up together nauy works on
sneaker designs with his childhood
friend who goes by te my art is best
when feed off of other people's ideas
and N is just somebody that like we just
click remember when I had the little the
carrot yeah why you take that off cuz it
was ugly in today's decentralized maker
economy despite running a small
independent clothing label NY was able
to contract directly with a manufacturer
in China to produce his inventory I'm
sending him a file of exactly what I
want I asked the manufacturers to send
videos of the whole process from scratch
you could get a good sneaker for about
$65 we sold 100 shoes at
$150 we didn't even triple
profit I don't like to break Pockets I
want the people from where I'm from to
be able to purchase it we made money
back but it was more so about pushing
the
art although naughty and T don't produce
enough shoes for Nike to take notice the
sneaker giant has been cracking down on
derivative designers the most
high-profile lawsuit is against BR
setting fashion brand of bathing ape or
Bape for short Bape is a really
important Japanese Street Wear brand
that started in the 1990s was embraced
by hip-hop Superstars Jay-Z and farell
probably the biggest among them Brendan
Dunn is the editor of the leading online
sneaker magazine Soul collector and
co-hosts the YouTube sneaker show
full-size run Bape was most known in
sneakers for making the bapesta which is
a version of the Air Force One that
replaces the Nike Swoosh with a a
shooting star logo across the side if
you look at the shoe and you know
anything about sneakers you know
immediately that's based on the Air
Force One I wanted bapes this bad when I
was a teenager and I'm happy to own a
few pairs now you know you put this next
to a Nike Air Force One and it should be
pretty obvious the DNA of the shoes you
don't have to be a sneaker obsessive to
see the things that these models have in
common this one came first this one came
later this year decades after the
original release of the bapa Nike
finally sued Bape over the design
calling the bapes a knockoff Air Force
One saying that Bape was infringing upon
Nike's intellectual property trade dress
around the Air Force One and asking the
court to stop Bape from selling these
shoes and this action from Nike comes
amid a wave of recent litigation where
they're trying to swat down all these
makers who create these shoes that look
a lot like Nike shoes and are very much
based on the success of Nike shoes it's
hard to know why exactly Nike has been
so aggressive recently I would speculate
that there are just more of them now
than there ever were before and this
looks to Nike like a whole cottage
industry that could get out of control
it seems like every 6 months there's a
new version of the Jordan 1 with a
different logo on it there some people
are just like oh those are knockoffs
those are fugazi but then there some
people that really look at it as all
right this is limited a collectible like
especially when you go hard with the box
and then you separate yourself with a
color way I feel like from like an
artistic standpoint like everything
comes from something nothing's truly
original like yeah this is something
you've seen before but it's it doesn't
take anything away from being personal
to
us we usually think that copying
actually destroys incentives to innovate
but in the Fashion World copying is
actually what creates the incentives to
innovate NYU Law Professor Christopher
sprigman is the co-author of the
knockoff economy how imitation Sparks
innovation in the book he draws a sharp
distinction between copyright trademark
in trade dress so copyright protects
artistic and literary Works trademark is
about symbols words
sounds that we use to identify the
source of products trade dress has a bit
of a different flavor to it which is
sometimes the shape of products or
elements of the products construction
tell us where the product comes from
trade dress is enforced in the fashion
industry occasionally but what you get
in a lot of lawsuits is some pretty
dubious claims of design being
recognizable when these lawsuits happen
inevitably the Nike litigators will come
up with screenshots from Instagram
comments of people who are confused and
are thinking this is a Nike shoe on some
level but I believe those people are in
the extreme extreme minority and that
anybody really spending their money on
shoes like this knows that Nike didn't
produce them or Nike is not involved
copying helps set Trends Trends cell
fashion copying is what helps kill
Trends copying is what helps set the
trend that comes next so the fashion
cycle runs and the fashion industry's
successive waves of innovation depend on
copying but sprigman sees a big
difference between derivatives such as
bapes or nai's designs and replicas or
Reps for short which attempt to mimic
Nike's models exactly making them a
clear case of trademark infringement
replica sneakers is not something that I
personally am a fan of it's totally fake
it's what we call in the street fuu we
don't do replicas replicas are not it I
was always taught you can't afford it
don't wear it I would never ever wear a
replica sneaker but when you think about
fake sneakers from the era when I
started collecting they were more
obviously fake a lot of the money spent
these days on replica sneakers has to do
with Recreations of shoes that are not
authorized by the companies but still
look exactly like and feel exactly like
or as close to exact as possible I think
it's definitely ironic if you consider
the fact that some of these shoes the
fake ones versus the real ones are made
in the same Factory by the same labor
force that is one of the harder pieces
to really square away in terms of not
wanting to ever wear fake shoes so if we
look at the placement of the Nike Air on
the label you can see that the air logo
at the bottom is placed slightly higher
and the label is actually a lot smaller
and Tighter on the fake pair compared to
the retail one videos like this help
buyers distinguish between replicas and
the real thing but most sneaker heads
aren't fooled by replicas they buy them
knowingly because the differences are so
subtle and the real thing is Out Of
Reach so Nike and adst in a sense have
learned what the luxury goods game is
about and they're getting into that game
they purposely manufacture fer than
could be sold they create scarcity this
scarcity helps create a mania this Mania
helps drive up the price on secondary
markets it seems to me that that kind of
behavior is going to call forth
counterfeits the way rain calls forth
flowers that's just the way the world
works unlike with knockoffs sprigman
believes that companies have a
legitimate case against replicas but
also sees it as a form of class bias
people should understand what they're
getting but if a person buys a
counterfeit and is not fooled I guess
the problem is that you'll be walking
out in the world with a very high
quality counterfeit luxury good that
other people will mistake for the real
thing when they mistake it for the real
thing they will impute to you the status
that in a sense you don't have we have
to ask ourselves are we really in the
business of regulating people's status
that's a business that says that the
person without a lot of money cannot
essentially signal to the world that
they have the kind of taste or that they
have the kind of means that a person
with more money has this is a way of
segmenting us by economic class using
intellectual property law as the means
and that is a very normatively
unattractive thing for intellectual
property law to be doing I do think
nekki is doing fine but I do still think
it's in their best interest to combat
counterfeits and knockoffs because I
believe that does divert Revenue away
from them but I feel like Nike's battle
against bootleg makers is a game of
whack-a-mole more than anything
else Bape is still selling its sneakers
and the company has filed for dismissal
of Nike's lawsuit a handful of other
cases have been dropped or settled out
of court with derivative designers
agreeing to stop selling their products
it's still not clear if Nike's legal
campaign will succeed in shutting down
this segment of the sneakers Market I
see myself expanding um I think kids now
are open to wearing different shoes
outside of just Nike Jordan there's so
many creators just because I feel like
social media plays a big
part fashion creativity comes from
design is looking at what other
designers are doing and playing with
those ideas copying is part of the cycle
that drives the industry
[Music]
forward